la convention citoyenne c'est
positionnée majoritairement à 75% en
faveur de l'aide active à mourir dans le
rapport vous pouvez aussi qu'il y a
quatre modèles des modèles avec du
suicide assisté et euthanasie au choix
suicide assister ou euthanasie par
exception suicide assisté seul
euthanasie seul le modèle suicide
assisté euthanasie au choix et celui qui
a remporté 40% des suffrages je rappelle
les principaux arguments en faveur de
l'aide active à mourir que nous avons
mis dans le dans le rapport premièrement
un cadre d'accompagnement actuel qui ne
répond pas à certaines situations de
souffrance comme les situations de
souffrance réfractaires tant physique
pour ne prendre que cet exemple 2 les
soins palliatifs sont complémentaires
mais ne répondent pas toutes les
situations des personnes en fin de vie
même avec le développement des soins
palliatifs resteront ces quelques
personnes dans les souffrances sont
inapaisables et qui souhaitent en être
soulagés
la troisième point l'aide d'activer à
mourir vient combler les limites de la
sédation profonde et continue jusqu'au
décès qui vous le savez ne peut
s'appliquer que sur une courte période
de la fin de vie car les médicaments
utilisés ont un effet limité dans le
temps or certaines agonies durent
plusieurs jours voire dépasse la semaine
ce sont ses passions donc Conseil d'État
parle quand il écrit qu'il n'en
finissent pas de mourir pour lesquels
nous pensons que les actives à mourir
pourrait être une solution les natives à
mourir réduit ce temps de l'agonie sous
l'agent celles et ceux qui n'ont choisi
la famille dans certaines situations les
soignants
autre point quatrième l'aide rective à
mourir mais fin aux situations
d'hypocrisie car l'euthanasie passive où
illégal quel que soit la façon qu'on la
nomme existe la mettre en oeuvre l'aide
d'active à mourir c'est faire entrer
dans le droit à une réalité c'est éviter
l'hypocrisie et protéger le corps
médical cinquième point l'aide d'activer
à mourir respectent la liberté de choix
des individus en offrant la possibilité
de préparer sa mort dans un cadre
sécurisé et de pouvoir inclure ses
proches dans le processus de fin de vie
elle permet aux personnes de décider des
conditions de leur fin de vie et de
choisir l'état de l'image qu'elle
souhaite laisser d'elle-même à leur
entourage au moment de leur mort sixième
point l'aide active à mourir permet une
fin de vie accompagnée et est un gage de
fraternité de solidarité c'est un moment
choisi et un moment accompagné légaliser
la haine pourrait transformer notre
rapport à la mort car on organisant
soi-même son départ le deuil de ses
proches pourrait être vécu différemment
et mieux accepter cela permettrait
d'éviter également des suicides violents
c'est proposer une mort solidaire au
lieu d'une mort solitaire